Okay great, let's continue. I think that you are still not really understand what's going on and it
happened to me as well. When at first time I was introduced to the bit dancer even
after several days of really hard digging in I still couldn't really
understand what are the manners, what are the validators, what are they doing.
So this is why we have this lecture today and it's longer than usual
so I hope that you have some sweets and tea or coffee. But yes speaking about
examples what really helped me is when one of the bit dancer team members
explained me on the very specific school metaphor. So take a look on the left we
have the subnet owner. It's kind of the principal in the school. The subnet owner
sets the rules and direction where this subnet is going and it's defining the
mission. So what goal this subnet want to achieve as well as on the high level it
make the performance criteria. On the right the school building itself. This
is the synonym of the subnet in other words is the infrastructure and shared
resources. These things about the subnet as a place is the infrastructure place
as the school building it provides some computational power and as well as data
so in other words is the platform for interaction of all the contributors. On
the left bottom there are validators in other words they think about them as a
teachers. They come up with the task they send this task to them to the
students and then they evaluate the students results of the student
performance and they grade. They make grading of
students performance as well as they ensure that no one is cheating. So they
ensure that there is no cheating from the students and the minors think about
them as a students itself. So they're trying to solve and crack the problems
to compete for the best possible solution and to gain the best the best
possible grades. They as well can cheat some time so the work of validator as
the teacher and the subnet owner as a principal to
so not to allow this cheating. Okay I hope that it's become more clear for
you. So for the subnets there are already a real world use cases. I can
break them into three main categories. The sharing computation when some people
share computational resources so the users can use them for example the
using of GPU or the even the full virtual machine. So we are using the
Google cloud platform to ram the virtual machine but there are same
solutions on the decentralized net. I think for the next next year we can we
can use them. The second big category is the shared AI decentralized AI
intelligent. These are things when the subnets trying to solve some big
problems. And the third main category is the subnets with a very specific goal. So
just to show you there is the tau starts. This is the website of bit tensor and as
you can see here here is the more than 125 subnets. Each one has the different
goals with the different solutions with different architectures and for example
the first subnet named tutors is the market cup is around 100 million dollars.
So you can see the market cup here in the tau and the tau price on the top
left here. Okay let me continue with the presentation and of course you can go
and check what the subnets are doing. I will show you just basic examples. So as I
mentioned there are subnets that provide computational shared resources and the
subnet number four, Tergon, is the computational marketplace. So the miners
they provide their GPUs, their machines and validators they make sure that miners
have good latency, good connection and also they are encrypted.
And for example basically for the GPU renting using the target it's cheaper
than to rent it from AWS or Azure or Google Cloud platform. So it's cheaper
more than two or sometimes three times. Okay the next subnet you've already seen
this picture right it's obviously was created with the nano banana from
Google and this is the AI picture. And the other subnet number 34
named Bitmind, it is the content verification platform. It allows to
detect AI generated content as well as to identify the deep fake content and
they have the very interesting architecture. They provide two types of
miners. One are generators of fakes or AI images or videos and the other ones is
discriminators. They upload detection models, models that can detect AI or
fakes. And the validators are responsible for challenging and scoring both minor
types. They even has the mobile app and this is right this is all freaking cool
the hot idea with the current AI market trend. And one more subnet is named 404
Gen. I'm the big fan of the Star Wars as well as I'm the biggest fan
of the French Bulldogs in the world and I generated this funny Bulldog Jedi and
this subnet it allows you to generate 3D content, 3D assets that you can
download and plug into your project. So the miners are
competing for providing the best 3D generation solution and the validators
are running the benchmark trying to decide which solution is the best. Okay
I will take a pause here and I will continue with the next video.